the rats are leaving the Trump ship yes
several of Trump's alleged
co-conspirators or no I guess verified
admitted co-conspirators at this point
are pleading guilty in Georgia our
resident prosecutor and Crim law expert
scow explains what that means for Sydney
Powell and others but things have been
happening just so fast and nobody wants
to be the last rat on the ship so stay
until the end where I talk about
immunity for Mark Meadows and Jenna
Ellis taking a plea deal as well cydney
Powell a former Trump lawyer and one of
19 defendants in the Fon County election
interference case just pled guilty to
improperly interfering in the 2020
presidential election pow shot to
internet infamy after she appeared on
Fox Business with a promise to release
the Kraken a reference to her belief
that the election was stolen by a
shadowy cabal of evildoers led by
Dominion voting systems it's been uh
organized and and conducted with the
help of Silicon Valley people the the
big tech companies the social media
companies and even the media companies
and I'm going to release the Kraken
Powell vowed exposed the perpetrators
and returned Trump to the White House
she filed lawsuits in swing States
across the country however every single
one of her lawsuits crashed and burned
or should we say torpedoed and drowned
because as it turns out Powell didn't
have a shred of evidence to support her
frankly unhinged conspiracy theories yet
every time the courts shot down Powell's
theories she doubled down on her claims
accusing everyone who disagreed with it
of being in on it here she is accusing
an Australian reporter of being
undercover for smartmatic what actual
research or factchecking did you do at
the time to find out what smart matic's
actual involvement in the election was
do you work for
smartmatic po walked out of that
interview after she was confronted with
her Lies when asked whether facts matter
Powell said yes they
do I hope we get to one of these days as
to what really happened in our election
and all the people who are responsible
for it well guess what we have finally
figured out who is responsible for what
happened in the election and the call
was coming from inside the house are you
pleading guilty today because you agree
that there is a sufficient factual basis
that there are enough facts that support
this plead of guilty I did howwell now
admits that she was the one who broke
the law not Dominion not smartmatic two
of her co-conspirators lawyer Ken the
cheese chesboro and bail bondsman Scott
Hall also plad guilty now that the do
are falling in fton County what does
this mean for Donald Trump Once Upon a
Midnight dreary Fox News became the
first Network to project that Biden won
Arizona it was the right call but it
proved to be a ratings disaster I'm
sorry the president is not going to be
able to take over and win enough votes
to eliminate that seven-point lead Fox
viewers viewed this as a betrayal and
they started to abandon the network this
created an opportunity for Sydney Powell
an imaginative lawyer with lots of
conspiracy theories about voting
machines pal appeared on network dozens
of times where she explained that
dominion and smartmatic used an
algorithm that flipped votes for Trump
to votes for Biden that probably ran all
over the country to take a certain
percentage of votes from president Trump
and flip them to President Biden which
we might never have uncovered had the
votes for president Trump not been so
overwhelming in so many of these states
that it broke the algorithm to be clear
this is all popular
behind the scenes Powell had presented
Fox News with a memo entitled election
fraud info that was written by an
anonymous source who claimed the wind
tells her she's a ghost box hosts
concluded that Powell was not playing
with a full deck Sydney Powell is a bit
nuts Fox host Laura Ingram wrote to
Tucker Carlson and Sean henned on
November 15th 2020 cydney Powell is
lying Carlson told his producer the next
day nevertheless Fox repeatedly turned
to Powell to win its view years back she
teamed up with Rudy Giuliani to promote
the theory that the election had been
stolen in November po met with other
Trump Loyalists and lawyer Lynn Woods
South Carolina estate which happens to
be a former rice Plantation called
cotton Hall the group included former
Overstock CEO Patrick burn Mike Flynn
and Doug Logan the CEO of cyber security
firm cyber ninjas Logan would later be
known as individual 25 in the Fon County
case the Trump gang enjoyed Thanksgiving
dinner at cotton Hall where Mike Flynn
was given the honor of carving the
turkey in between servings of mashed
potatoes and cranberry sauce the group
brainstormed ways that Trump would still
win the election wood remembers Powell
making phone calls to Georgia and
theorizing that the communist government
of Venezuela played a role in Biden's
Victory eventually they agreed that they
needed to get their hands on digital
copies of data and software used on
voting machines meanwhile down in
Georgia Powell's theories got the
attention of election officials in
Coffee County Georgia a rural County
where over 70% of of Voters chose Donald
Trump despite Trump's Big Win local
elections officials decided that someone
had tampered with their voting machines
these officials included Kathy leam
Misty Hampton Eric Cheney and Ed voils
they all agreed that the election had
been riged later they would participate
in an alleged conspiracy to give
unauthorized people access to voting
equipment in December pow cided Coffee
County to make her case to Donald Trump
that the federal government should seize
the voting machines she helped draft two
orders that would have authorized the
seizure citing Coffee County as proof
that the orders were Justified on
December 18th pow met with Trump and
urged him to appoint her as special
counsel to investigate voter fraud
needless to say Trump did not go forward
with seizing the voting machines but
Powell and Giuliani hatched a plan to
obtain the machines voluntarily Powell
already had a contract with a forensic
company called Sullivan stickler to
inspect voting machines in Michigan the
Georgia indictment alleges that Powell
Paul also brought the group to Georgia
the indictment says pal paid Sullivan
strickler for the purpose of willfully
tampering with electronic ballot markers
and tabulating machines which were overt
acts to affect the object of the
conspiracy to interfere with the result
in December Georgia completed a third
machine recount of the vote however
Coffee County refused to certify the
outcome claiming an inability to
repeatedly duplicate creditable election
results the county determined that its
vote count was off by 51 votes
when the Georgia Secretary of State
investigated he found that the
discrepancy was caused by human error
probably because Hampton couldn't
remember if she scanned a stack of
ballots twice or not but the
conspirators were not about to give up
and that's how they ended up
codefendants with Sydney Powell on
January 7th the day after the ride at
the capital these local officials
allowed people from Sven strickler to
spend hours examining voting systems in
the county as you can see in this
security video pal allegedly paid them
for their time Scott Hall a bail
bondsman and future codefendant flew
down from Atlanta to help once in the
Coffee County elections office the
analysts copied Georgia Statewide voting
system software according to a recorded
phone call they scanned all the
equipment imaged all the hard drives and
scanned every single ballot we scanned
every freaking ballot the defendants
also took official ballots outside of
the polling place well as it turns out
Georgia law requires ballots to remain
in the custody of election officials and
Superior Court clerks at all times
according to the indictment the
defendants and co-conspirators stole
data including ballot images voting
equipment software and personal voter
information the stolen data was then
distributed to other members of the
Enterprise including members in other
states now Trump was not indicted for
the Coffee County data breach but Powell
and the locals were in a heap of trouble
of their own now if I can interject if
you ever find yourself thinking about
taking a plea deal for converting
democracy you'll probably need a good
lawyer but if you want a great lawyer my
firm the eagle team can help if you've
been in a car crash suffered from sexual
harassment or are dealing with Social
Security Disability or workers comp
issues we can represent you or help find
you the right attorney who can it's so
important to talk to a lawyer right away
so you don't lose your chance for a full
recovery so just click on the link in
the description for a free consultation
with my team because you don't just need
a legal team you need the eagle team the
link is below Fon County district
attorney fonnie Willis charged Powell
with seven felony counts including
racketeering conspir iry to commit an
election fraud conspiracy to commit
computer trespass and conspiracy to
defraud the state at first pal
vigorously contested the charges arguing
that it should have been removed to
federal court now she lost that argument
and trial was slated to begin in mid-
October on her own
request however instead of going to
trial on seven felonies po pled guilty
to six misdemeanors po pled guilty to
one count of conspiracy to commit theft
by taking and five counts of conspiracy
to commit intentional interference with
performance of election
duties the plea agreement calls for her
to be sentenced to 6 years of probation
pay a $6,000 fine pay $2,700 in
restitution and to write an apology
letter to the citizens of Georgia the
agreement requires her to provide
truthful testimony at trial and other
proceedings have no Communications with
codefendants Witnesses or the media
until all the cases have concluded and
to give a full profer and provide
documents in other words pal has
promised to give Willis the whole
interest
of evidence against her codefendants
since pow pled guilty before the Coffee
County locals she actually might end up
getting a better plea deal than the
people who followed her off the cliff in
addition to the breach of voting
machines in Coffee County the
prosecution will ask her about the White
House meeting where she encouraged Trump
to give her the power to investigate
voter fraud in addition to the breach of
voting machines in Coffee County the
prosecution will ask her about the White
House meeting where she encouraged Trump
to give her power to investigate
so-called voter fraud Cod defendants
Jeffrey Clark John Eastman and Rudy
Giuliani will be the hardest hit why did
Powell plead guilty now well many of the
codefendants in this case were trying to
pin everything on her especially Rudy
Giuliani in August Rudy's lawyer said
you can't attach Rudy Giuliani to Sydney
Powell's crackpot idea so one way of
viewing this is that she turned on him
before he could turn on her some people
were shocked that Powell pled guilty but
she had more or less admitted her lies
after dominion sued her for defamation
po filed a motion to dismiss the lawsuit
on the grounds that no reasonable person
would conclude that the statements were
truly statements of fact Powell had
claimed that she had evidence that the
election result was the greatest crime
of the century if not the life of the
world but in her motion she said that
reasonable people understand that the
language of the political Arena like the
language used in labor disputes is often
vituperative abusive and and inexact she
said that her audience could easily find
the evidence and decide for themselves
US District Court Judge Carl Nichols
ruled against Powell the question is
whether a reasonable juror could
conclude that Powell's statements
expressed or implied a verifiably false
fact about Dominion this is not a close
call Judge Nichols a trump appointee
also said Powell may have fabricated her
affidavit and that her expert reports
were unreliable that expert has also
publicly claimed that George Soros
president George HW Bush's father the
Muslim Brotherhood and leftists helped
form the Deep state in Nazi Germany in
the 1930s which would have been a
remarkable feat for Soros who was born
in 1930 now Powell wasn't the first
Domino to fall in fton county that honor
is reserved for Scott Hall Hall was the
first Trump defendant in any
jurisdiction to make a deal with
prosecutors Hall was charged with
several felonies including conspiracy to
commit election fraud conspiracy to
commit computer theft conspiracy to
commit computer trespass consp
conspiracy to commit computer invasion
of privacy and conspiracy to defraud the
state H pled guilty to five misdemeanor
accounts of conspiracy to commit
intentional interference with the
performance of an election H will be
sentenced to 5 years probation pay a
$5,000 fine serve 200 hours of community
service and write a letter of apology he
also has to testify against other
codefendants now Hall played a pivotal
role in the Coffee County scheme he was
part of a secret text message group that
coordinated the data theft pa exchange
messages with Coffee County official
Eric Cheney about giving the forensics
team an open invitation to access voting
machines the indictment alleges that
Hall's actions essentially mirrored
Powells as both of them coordinated
Sullivan strickler's actions Hall also
reached out to Lyn wood and another
lawyer Carlos Silva about helping Trump
Hall eventually signed a false affidavit
insisting that he had personally
observed ballots that appeared to be
pre-printed with the selections already
made the affidavit says hundreds of
ballots at a time were counted for Biden
only Woods submitted the affidavit as an
exhibit in Wood V raffensberger which
was one of the doomed Trump lawsuits
that tried to stop certification of the
Georgia result Hall presumably knew this
avate was false when he submitted it
funny Willis got a third guilty plea
when lawyer Ken chesbro plad guilty
right before his trial started chesbro
is allegedly the architect of the fake
elector scheme chesbro was the first
defendant to plead guilty to a felony he
pled guilty to one count of conspiracy
to commit filing false documents in
violation of Georgia Code section
161201 which says it's unlawful to
knowingly file enter or record any
document in a public record or Court of
the state or of the United States
knowing or having reason to know that
such document is false or contains a
materially false fictitious or
fraudulent statement of representation
the judge ordered chesbro to serve 5
years of probation pay $5,000 in
restitution complete one 100 hours of
community service write a letter of
apology and testify truthfully at trial
as part of his plea deal chesbro
admitted that he conspired to put
forward fake GOP electors in Georgia
with Trump and former Trump lawyers Rudy
Giuliani and John Eastman this probably
means chesbro will testify against both
Giuliani and Eastman with chesbro and
Powell pleading guilty there won't be a
trial in Georgia until 2024 that means
Trump and the other defendants won't get
a preview of the prosecutor's arguments
in cases with multiple codefendants
early Cooperators usually get the best
deals however some have argued that
these deals are especially lenient so
how good were these
deals well Fulton County District's
attorney fonny Willis even agreed to put
on the record that chz bro's felony did
not constitute a crime of moral
turpitude the moral turpitude language
is important in a variety of contexts
and it might help chesbro maintain his
law license although the final Authority
rests with the board authorities in the
jurisdictions where he's licensed to
practice so let's talk about cooperator
deals typically prosecutors Focus their
efforts on convicting the most morally
culpable people the leaders the planners
the trigger pullers prosecutors will try
to get less culpable people to flip the
Lookouts the getaway drivers the
flunkies and prosecutors will virtually
always incentivize people to flip by
offering the most lenient deals to the
first ones in the door typically that
means starting at the bottom and working
up the ladder Paul Rosen swag a lecturer
at George Washington University law
school and ex-deputy assistant secretary
for policy at the Department of Homeland
Security said the deals reveal Willis's
strategy this is beginning to look like
a classic case of rolling up the small
fry to get to the Capo so you would
expect the smallest fish to plead first
like the Coffee County officials for
example but in this case chesboro and
Powell and Hull are more like
lieutenants they engaged in planning and
coordinating so why did they plead
guilty when they did well as far as
Powell and chesbro go they demanded
Speedy trials and severing their cases
from the rest of the codefendants they
got their wish which created an
interesting Dynamic prosecutors and
defense attorneys across the country see
a pattern play out over and over again
defendants who are not in pre-trial
detention can have a really hard time
wrapping their heads around a plea deal
just up until trial is looming until the
reality of what they're facing is right
in front of them for chesbro and Powell
their trials were set to begin within
days of their pleas their own speedy
trial demand put pressure on them and
prosecutors to figure out a deal well
before some of the arguably smaller fish
now I don't know whether it was a good
idea to give chesbro and Powell the
deals they got Bonnie Willis is the one
who knows what the evidence shows she
may believe that they will give the most
damning evidence against the other
codefendants especially the big fish
himself Donald Trump and with her
experience in full County she probably
has a good sense for what chesbro and
Powell were really looking at if they
were convicted at trial in other words
what kind of Leverage she actually had
to get them to plead guilty to lesser
charges and cooperate the RICO charges
against Powell Hall and chesbro were
dropped some people suggest that means
the RICO charges were prosecutorial
overreach but it's common for
cooperating codefendants to get
dismissals of the most serious charges
apparently Powell has already recorded a
proper video with Georgia prosecutors
laying out the details of the crime and
locking her into a story if they haven't
already chesbro and Hall will do the
same with those three locked in and
cooperating we can expect numerous other
codefendants to come to the table and
agree to similar deals but poell and chz
br's guilty pleas have implications
Beyond just Georgia special Council Jack
Smith's January 6th indictment of trump
includes descriptions of unindicted
co-conspirators whose descriptions match
Powell and chesbro Mitchell EP a former
Federal prosecutor puts it simply
neither has plea protection from federal
charges they could be leveraged into
becoming cooperating Witnesses in the
case before judge chucken neither would
have a viable defense in that case given
their Georgia pleas so even without any
kind of coordination Bonnie Willis may
have just delivered to Jack Smith an
early present for the holidays and the
Christmas presents keep coming because
ABC News reported that Mark Meadows
received immunity from the special
counsel and testified before the grand
jury in the election in interference
case in Washington DC Meadow was
indicted in Georgia but not Washington
DC now immunity for prosecution means
that a person is shielded from Criminal
prosecution for an offense and there are
two types of immunity the first is
transactional immunity which protects a
witness from being prosecuted for
anything they testified about and the
second is called use immunity which
protects the witness from the use of
their own testimony against them but
does not prevent the government from
using other evidence obtained from
independent sources to prosecute that
witness and a grant of immunity removes
a person's Fifth Amendment right against
self self incrimination so that's why
reporters have concluded that Meadows
was compelled to testify by a grant of
immunity but there's still lots of
unanswered questions about Meadows and
his lawyer has been quick to shoot down
claims that he's flipped or is
cooperating ABC reported that Meadows
told prosecutors he knew the allegations
of voter fraud were false and that he
repeatedly told Trump he was wrong so
Meadows unlike Jenna Ellis is probably
not a cooperating witness and it remains
to be seen whether Meadows will take a
deal in Georgia he was involved in
Trump's phone call to Brad raffensberger
the perfect call and he was with Trump
as the January 6th right unfolded and
Meadows probably had the best legal
argument that his Georgia case should be
removed to Federal Court although he
lost the first round of that case and
his appeal is scheduled to be heard in
November but if he loses that then maybe
he will be willing to take a deal in
Georgia how that will impact his role in
the DC case is something we will no
doubt be talking about later and on the
other end of the spectrum Jenna Ellis is
the latest to become the personification
of the how it started how it's going
meme this was Jenna Ellis back on
September 7th and here's Jenna Ellis now
I relied on others including lawyers
with many more years of experience than
I to provide me with true and reliable
information especially since my role
involved speaking to the media and to
legislators in various States what I did
not do but should have done your honor
was to make sure that the facts the
other lawyers alleged to be true were in
fact true in the frenetic pace of
attempting to raise challenges to the
election in several States including
Georgia I failed to do my due diligence
I believe in and I value election
Integrity if I knew then what I know now
I would have declined to represent
Donald Trump in these post-election
challenges I look back on this whole
experience with deep remorse now the
other lawyer with many more years of
experience than Ellis is Rudy Giuliani
the indictment alleges that Ellis
shadowed Rudy as he made his case for
the appointment of fake electors in the
swing States Ellis is accused of
soliciting and importuning members of
the Georgia legislature to serve as fake
electors she also wrote a legal
memorandum addressing to Trump uh which
quote outlined a strat stry for
disrupting and delaying The Joint
session of Congress on January 6 2021
concluding that the Vice President
should not open any of the votes from
Six States including Georgia neon Willis
charged Ellis under the Georgia RICO
statute with solicitation of violating a
public officer's oath and under the
terms of the plea deal Ellis agreed to a
single felony count of aiding and
abetting false statements and writings
so why did Ellis plead to a felony well
probably because she was caught telling
specific lies to legislators to convince
them to submit a slate of fake electors
and Ellis's lies were very spe specific
such as claiming that more than 10,000
dead people voted and over 66,000
underage people voted knowing that that
was untrue but it's not surprising that
Ellis is pleading out we did rank her in
the F tier and possibly because of that
her attempts to fundraise her defense
did not go great now that's a whole
thing we don't want people pleading
guilty simply because they cannot afford
a defense here it's unclear what
happened but also the allegations are
reasonably strong and the Colorado bar
has already disciplined Ellis for making
10 false statements while she
represented Trump the bar could seek her
disbarment or suspension for the felony
conviction Ellis claimed to have raised
$200,000 for her legal defense fund
which is a lot of money but probably not
nearly enough to pay for a yearl long
defense in multiple fronts and Ellis's
plea puts America's mayor on the hot
seat but now that Powell cheesbro and
Ellis have taken pleas hopefully we'll
never see them in public again and I'm
sure that they would appreciate if they
could scrub their information out of the
public domain which they could do with
today's sponsor incog now I don't know
about you but I've seen a huge uptick in
the of spam I'm getting it's no surprise
why every year the number in scope of
data breaches worldwide is rising and
you might not know it but there are
hundreds of data Brokers that possess
and sell your personal information and
their numbers grow every year these data
Brokers might have a whole Shadow
profile on you including your name your
address your phone number shopping
habits possibly even your social
security number all up for the highest
bidder and at best this leads to scam
calls and at worst identity theft and
doxing so for example if you're getting
tons of robocalls to your cell phone or
calls from scammers like I am basically
every day there's a good chance it's
because your data is online and
sometimes it's completely legal but
totally nefarious like health insurance
companies raising their rates because
they got access to your personal health
data but that's where incognit comes in
incog fights on your behalf to remove
your personal data from data Brokers and
deals with any objections from their
side all you have to do is create an
account and give them approval to work
on your behalf incognate conducts
repeated ongoing removals because if a
broker removes your data once they can
collect it again but incog makes sure
that your personal information stays off
the market for good and you can see when
incog does this on your personal
dashboard this is mine it shows that
these three sites had data on me that
was rated 10 out of 10 on incog
sensitivity scale those Brokers had my
data included my contacts financial data
and Health Data thankfully incog tells
me when the removal requests are
complete so I can breathe easy but it's
really fun to watch incog get them to
delete that info one by one so if you'd
like to give incog a try click on the
link below to get 60% off of incog when
you use the code legal eagle again to
get an exclusive 60% off discount just
click on the link that's on screen right
now or down in the description and use
the code legal eagle after that click on
this link over here for more legal eagle
or I'll see you in court